ABOUT MASK WEARING, NO ONE IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> JOINING US TO DISCUSS,
ANOTHER TOP STORY, LET’S BRING
IN THE POLITICAL PANEL, LEO
TERREL AND RADIO SHOW HOST
RICHARD FOWLER, BOTH ARE FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTORS.
THIS MAY BE THE GREAT MASK
DEBATE, THE TIMING OF THIS
ABOUT-FACE, FROM CDC, IT WASN’T
OKAY, BECAUSE THE SCIENCE
WASN’T OFF.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS FOLLOWING
THE SCIENCE OR IS IT POLITICAL?
>> LET’S BE VERY CLEAR IT IS
PURELY POLITICS, A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO THAT CDC DIRECTOR CHANGED
HER STORY TO GIVE A PERSONAL
OPINION.
2 WEEKS AGO THE CDC TALKED
ABOUT IF YOU’RE HAVING TO HAVE
YOUR KIDS GO TO SUMMER CAMP YOU
GOT TO WEAR A MASK.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, IT IS VERY
SIMPLE YOU HAVE A BORDER
CRISIS.
IT IS TOTAL CHAOTIC WHITE
HOUSE.
THE FINAL POINT IS SCHOOL
TEACHERS, ON MARTHA MACCALLUM’S
SHOW HOLDING BACK KIDS, AND IT
IS STRICTLY POLITICS, NOT EVEN
HAVE A VACCINE.
>> DO YOU AGREE?
>> HERE’S WHAT WE KNOW.
AS MORE AMERICANS, WE GET
CLOSER TO HEARD IMMUNITY.
THEY GO TO THEIR DOCTOR AND
PHARMACIST AND THEY BECOME
VACCINATED, AS THEY ROLLED BACK
MANY REGULATIONS IN THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC KILLED 600,000
AMERICANS.
WE ARE AT THE POINT THAT IF YOU
ARE VACCINATED, DOESN’T TAKE
AWAY THE FACT THAT MANY DON’T
HAVE MASK MANDATES IN PLACE,
THE COVID RATES REMAIN HIGH AND
HAVE TO OPERATE WITH SOME
VIGILANCE TO PROTECT THOSE
AROUND YOU INCLUDING
GRANDPARENTS AND
IMMUNOCOMPROMISED INCLUDING
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS.
IT IS A MULTISTEP APPROACH, TO
SHUT THE GOVERNMENT DOWN AND
SHUT THE COUNTRY DOWN IT TAKES
A LOT TO REOPEN AND THAT IS
WHAT THIS IS WE ARE SEEING.
>> GOT TO STOP PLAYING THIS.
GENERALIZE TALKING POINT.
CANNOT DENY THE FACT OF THE
BORDER, CANNOT DENY THE FACT
THAT 13 RED STATES HAD THEIR
STATES OPEN ALL THE TIME.
SCHOOLS ARE OPEN.
DON’T PLAY THE TALKING POINT,
IT HASN’T HAPPENED, PEOPLE ARE
NOT WORKING.
AND INFLATION RATE, TALK ABOUT
THE FACT, GO ON THE FOX NEWS
PROGRAM, GIVE US A SPECIFIC
FACT BUT TELL ME I AM WRONG.
>> QUICK RESPONSE.
>> JUMPING ALL OVER THE MAP.
THE FACTS --
>> NEGATIVE ISSUE.
>> I DIDN’T INTERRUPT YOU SO
DON’T INTERRUPT ME.
MORE AND MORE AMERICANS GET
VACCINATED WE ARE MOVING CLOSER
TO BEING REOPEN, MOVING CLOSER
TO GOING BACK TO WHAT MOM
LOOKED LIKE PRE-PANDEMIC BUT
THAT WILL REQUIRE FOLKS TO GET
ONE OR 2 SHOTS, WE THREE WEEKS
TO BE FULLY IMMUNE FROM COVID
19 AND THAT IS THE FACT, NO
TALKING POINT.
>> GOT TO LET IT GO.
TO BE CONTINUED ON ANOTHER DAY,